bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors cette
proposition de loi sécurité globale a
été adoptée en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale elle doit être
examiné par le sénat en mars ses
opposants exigent en particulier le
retrait de cet article 24 qui interdit
la diffusion d'image des membres des
forces de l'ordre dans l'intention de
nuire à leur intégrité qu'elle soit
physique ou psychique
la majorité présidentielle a annoncé
l'entière réécriture de cet article mais
les opposants au texte dénonce son
recyclage dans l'article 18 du projet de
loi sur le séparatisme quel est votre
regard
alors écoutez le l'article 24 de la loi
de sécurité globale présente un problème
essentiellement symboliques puisque le
le fait de mettre en danger des
personnes est déjà puni par la loi
le texte que j'ai pu consulter et qui se
trouve dans la loi conditions de
séparatisme à mon sens mais suppose
peut-être une analyse un peu plus
approfondie à mon sens beaucoup mieux
écrits et concerne lui tout un chacun
c'est à dire que c'est plus une réaction
à l'attentât qu'il ya eu contre monsieur
samuel pâtit qui a justifié de la une
proposition de l'arctique qui se trouve
dans le texte sur le séparatisme qui est
beaucoup mieux décrit maintenant la loi
sur les séparatistes posé énormément de
problèmes
par ailleurs est le problème si vous
voulez c'est que le symbolisme de cet
article 24 qui pose problème dans cet
article fait que le lien parti pris
évident de
l'état par rapport aux forces de l'ordre
alors que il ya une colère citoyenne vis
à vis des forces de l'ordre qui ne fait
que s'accroître
donc la stratégie du gouvernement est
manifestement contre-productif pour
rétablir le dialogue qu'on appelle tous
nos voeux est ce qu'on trouve le juste
équilibre entre protection des forces de
l'ordre et liberté de manifester
d'informer de filmer les manifestations
alors il ya simplement il ya tout
simplement je vois qu'il faut pas dit on
pas complexifier le débat et la réponse
et elle est très simple il n'ya rien
d'incompatible dans tout ça c'est à dire
que filmer un policier en train de faire
son travail à partir du moment où il
fait son travail correctement et que le
fait de filmer ne porte pas atteinte à
son action ne doit pas poser de
difficulté le fait de l'interdire sacré
suppose que on veut sans péché les
citoyens de se ménager l'épreuve
d'éventuels abus or jouera que je me
permets de rappeler quelque chose de
fondamental en démocratie et que on a
des élus à qui on délègue une partie de
notre souveraineté qui ont le devoir
d'adopter des doigts qui sont conformes
aux idéaux républicains
mais qu'y aura-t-il devoir de contrôler
l'action du gouvernement le gouvernement
et le hiérarchique et hiérarchiquement
le supérieur de la police nationale et
de toutes les forces de l'ordre du pays
alors à la fois dans la noix sécurité
globale le fait de déléguer la mission
de service public régaliennes de
sécurité pose un problème des mecs
démocratique évident mais en plus on
empêchant en interdisant aux citoyens de
filmer l'action de la police on les
retire une une partie et contiennent de
face aux vagues et qui est le contrôle
de l'action publique
les adversaires de la proposition de loi
sécurité globale demandent aussi le
retrait des articles 21 et 22 qui porte
à la fois sur l'usagé des caméras
piétons et des drones par les forces de
l'ordre
est ce que ces deux mesures sont
symboles selon vous d'une ultra
surveillance de la société qu'elles
risquent aussi de dérives et comment les
empêcher selon vous il faut il faut à
mon avis élargir la perspective et se
rappeler aussi que conseil d'état vient
de valider le fichage des citoyens par
rapport à leurs opinions
si on a une société dans laquelle les
forces de l'ordre qui sont au service de
l'état et donc du pouvoir et donc des
dirigeants est une élite particulière on
l'est ont les moyens de surveiller
contre leur gré et à un point qu'on n'a
jamais connu jusqu'aujourd'hui les
activités des citoyens
on va limiter la liberté de conscience
la liberté politique et en syrie gérard
un régime
pardonnez-moi de grossir le trait mais
on tend réellement vers un régime
totalitaire qui va ressembler dans 50
ans parce que sont en train de
développer les chinois aujourd'hui il ya
cette question de vue du nouveau schéma
national du maintien de l'arnette
détracteurs demandent sa suppression
qu'est ce qui ne passe pas dans ce
schéma est ce que ça vous semble
pertinent ces critiques pardon vous
pouvez répéter la question sur la
question du maintien du nouveau schéma
national du maintien de l'ordre
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui cloche selon
vous je n'ai pas la référence donc je
pourrais pas vous répondre je suis
désolé mais en tout cas merci d'avoir
pris le temps de répondre à ces quelques
questions tenant les charges rappelle
que vous êtes avocat au barreau de paris